Monday morning of course last night the
first night of Hanukkah a Fremont Street
Experience lit that 20-foot tall Grand
Menorah that music they had dancing as
the first candle was that we've been
learning all about that by the way those
dancing dreidels you see there from
Shabbat of Southern Nevada they're going
to be right here in the 8 news now
Studio on Wednesday morning you know
Hanukkah lasts for eight days so the
final day will be a week from today
Monday the 26th John Heather all right
Nate it it's now 6 43 So speaking of
Hanukkah again eight wonderful nights of
Celebration a celebration of light it is
Hanukkah we're talking about it that's
right Jewish celebration began last
night at sundown and as Candice Charles
was going to join us here the community
has so many ways to celebrate she's with
Jewish Nevada this morning hi Candace
good morning
good morning YouTube good morning folks
as Heather just mentioned there are so
many ways to celebrate the eight days of
Hanukkah one of the ways is actually
eating as you guys saw me do a little
earlier but also playing some games so
I'm joined by Jewish Nevada's Stephanie
Tasman thank you so much for joining us
tell us about this game I've played a
few times I think I'm good at it I don't
know we'll see yeah while you are a good
guy a good riddle spinner but dreidel is
a traditional game played on Hanukkah
and um very Vegas it's actually a
gambling game so you start with a pot of
gout or money sometimes chocolate these
are chocolate coins you spin a dreidel
okay she's going for the first one yes
whatever it lands on uh tells you what
you win so Shin means I actually have to
give something back to the pot so not
off to a great start I'm gonna try to
give it a try tell us real quickly how
can people celebrate uh the eight days
of Hanukkah here in Nevada there's so
much happening throughout the valley to
celebrate Hanukkah during these eight
days Jewish Nevada is hosting a Hanukkah
excuse me a menorah lighting Wednesday
at downtown Summerlin at 4 pm but the
Chabad also hosts Menorah lightings
throughout the valley you can find out
more at our website jewishnevada.org
okay you guys missed this wonderful spin
but I got gimmel what does that mean
that's all I get it all this feels like
Vegas because it is thank you so much
Stephanie for chatting with us this
morning for all of that you do for the
community we really appreciate it of
course you guys can find out more
details on our website 8newsnow.com for
now live from juice Nevada I'm Candace
Charles